[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
[Music]
delicious i gotta adjust my microphone
here i've been we've been out of the
studio for a little bit
so uh thank you glad to be with you and
uh yeah we were in phoenix we were in
houston uh and uh so it's been a little
it's been a minute yeah
it was great here really quickly before
we get to anything look at cnn that's
the slender man right now he haunts your
dreams
that man on the right
[Laughter]
did someone did someone narrow the
picture and not hit shift
we have makeup no
no no no we have we have scary makeup
yes
oh yeah just give me the party city
stuff all right
so we have a lot to get to today uh a
couple of things first off you know
trudeau has obviously ruined queen
forever um
we have desantis is a big big story
right now we weren't able to talk about
it since uh you know thursday uh we were
on the road and we had a super video
yesterday i recommend that you go and
watch it with the uh the gay man who
wanted to be blurred and didn't want his
voice to be heard and i thought it was
incredibly uh revealing we've had that a
lot when we've been on the road a lot of
people come up and talk to us and say
you know we're afraid of speaking out in
our workplace so that's why we do this
show we're supported by you mug club
loudwise right now
is under investigation
for doing something that uh former vice
president joe biden has done uh always
you may not know that he's been flying
illegal immigrants across this country
uh for his entire presidency and i think
when you actually understand people are
saying this is a pr stunt 12 million
dollars do you know how much comment
below before i get to it later in the
show how much do you think
illegal immigrants cost the american
taxpayer every year
okay we'll get to it you're wrong it's
higher
and something else that i really want to
talk about today is you saw this ohio
police officer female officer get
pummeled get overpowered and uh
look may not be a popular opinion but i
don't think that uh women should be on
the police force in scenarios where they
could run into violent altercations same
thing with the military will a video
proof as to why you may not agree with
me but i would like to see far fewer
women getting pummeled and thrown over a
cop car okay so gerald a you are with me
today how are you i am well sir how are
you i'm fine i'm just adjusting this
microphone here because it's one that's
not you take take the reins here first
second was a good time we had several
thousand people in houston you guys had
a great time in phoenix we uh you know
yeah appreciate everybody coming out and
supporting the show we'd love to be able
to get on the road and do that
speaking of which you know you love him
he's also here with us and he's going to
be we're doing some more shows by the
way there's first show sold out in
nashville yeah but on november 12th
we've added a 9 30 show a second show
which is
two-thirds sold out uh at the ryman
auditorium and then baltimore december
3rd we continue with the shows and he is
going to be uh in bay city october 1st
go see him uh mr landau dave how are you
sir ahoy good how about you so you went
in and said give me a little boys cut i
did i said i well
i actually was able to fit in the
airplane the tiny one and yeah they just
they did it away with it did they turn
it on and like rock for a minute just to
get you comfortable that's correct yeah
no i don't think does your do you
aggravate your neighbor wilson i do
i have a slingshot in my back pocket
which is why i'm sitting funny
actually we're sitting funny because uh
we have some we'll get to this in a
second jessica yeah big old we're going
to live our authentic self we have a lot
to do with canada today transgender
teacher with giant fake tits like i'm
talking double z's if that's a thing
very sexy yes yes and the school is
standing by him sorry her
okay it's a man with udders
it is man and spandex
so i want to hit this here first uh have
you guys all watched this the ohio the
uh willowby police department
have you have you seen it yet dave i saw
bits i saw bits yeah okay
so this there's a woman here it's what
should be a routine traffic stop goes
awry and this is last wednesday on the
14th it doesn't have that many plays but
this is something that is becoming all
too common and it's by design so it's
not just an isolated incident i don't
believe that women should be in
positions of law enforcement as you see
here and neither do they as you will see
from the clip this happened ohio's
willoughby police department let's watch
hello
monster i will be placed on right that's
why i'm stopping you to speed 57 and 35.
why are you getting out of the car sir
you have gloves on
i feel like you're ready to commit
murder
step over here now i got [ __ ]
back off back up i'm not sitting
[ __ ]
put your hands behind your back
oh she said that with authority take
your gloves off michael jackson oh my
it happened so quickly he was gardening
so now
oh
patriarchy has to run in yep there he
goes again the patriarchy doing things
for a woman when they don't even ask
hey can we pull have them pull that clip
to the final part of that clip remember
there's a lady who comes in and says you
don't ever do that to a woman another
female police officer guys grab that
clip from me she goes you don't ever do
that to him when they're restraining the
guy like what
what happened
what happened to just being yeah men and
women are the same and the police well
you see that physically that's not the
case she gets overpowered very quickly
and then their defense when they go in
is don't ever do that to a woman oh this
is a criminal he's treating the female
cop the exact same as he would treat a
male cop yeah yeah aren't you
automatically a serial killer though if
you pull somebody over and they're just
wearing gloves i think so this is pretty
much
i'm like hey he's getting out of his car
now um uh central what do i do yeah
uh speak sternly to him sir he's wearing
gloves and his trunk is a vat of acid
yes what do i do he's asking me to get
in yeah should i he has a drum and two
femurs to play it with there's a basket
with lotion what do i do there's a small
poodle he's tucked his skin suit let's
watch that again while they pull the
rest of that next clip i want you to see
this is something that should be a
routine traffic stop and what is
required
is a cop a police officer should be and
this applies to men but particularly to
women because women in general cannot be
as strong as
as criminal men as a general rule are
there some exceptions sure but a lot of
police officers are subpar for the
fitness standards for the strength
standards a police officer should be
at least at the performance level above
the average man yeah because they need
to subdue the average man what if it's a
slightly above average man this is not
an above average man it's a well below
this is a well below average man and he
rag dolls her like a child yeah how is
this equality let's watch this again and
then we'll pull the uh the end to that
clip
hello
monster i will be placed on her that's
why i'm stopping you this speed 57 and
35.
that's going pretty fast actually
yeah it is and she shouldn't let him do
this
he could be grabbing a gun right now and
she's dead
it's just
stupid
you step over here now i got [ __ ]
all she said was sit down and she gets
physical
and here's the problem she gets physical
with no ability to back it up correct
this is not a technical grappling
endeavor this is just a man ragdolling a
woman because she's weaker than a man
she has no ability to defend herself
and now here comes in a pot-bellied man
in flip-flops and he's able to do the
job with the highly trained professional
ken knox
and another man
and a third man
do they have that clip there kevin
so the end of the clip then this is how
it ends where finally the female
supervisor comes in and this is what she
has to say because uh this is how you
know you're you're safe is in your
mother's arms and quite literally it
could just be your mother's arms let's
play it shut up
you don't do that to a woman
do you understand me
did you understand me no i don't i don't
understand you
chivalry cups
the guy's going what do you mean i don't
do that to women i i do this to cops
yeah isn't she a cop i mistreat cops i'm
a criminal yeah by the way taser she the
the minute he gets out of his car and
doesn't comply
i'm like just hope just tase him and
then tase him again and maybe tase him
again i don't know oh yeah like see if
he can break dance he's white you could
have shot him yeah
would have been fine and here's the
problem is the more you remove tools and
by the way the more you have these
diversity hires these equality hires and
the police force guess what you're gonna
end up with more police brutality police
violence because they have to go to
their tool belt right they have to go to
their firearms so let me give you an
example here the police academy fitness
standards in ohio
well it's a double standard you have
sit-ups right
one minute how many sit-ups can you do
for men you have to do 33 in one minute
which is not a lot no women 24. what the
push-ups test for a police officer in
ohio a man has to do 22 in one minute
which is really not that much slow woman
has to do 10.
in other words a police officer the male
officer has to do twice as many what do
you think is going to happen when that
woman runs into a man in the street well
you just saw what happened
1.5 mile run the men it's four 14
minutes six seconds women 16 minutes 46
seconds
also not fast on the male side no no
what if you fail the test as a man
couldn't you just say you're not a yeah
you're a woman we'll get to that
and we're there yes we're okay we got
right there okay just wanted to make
sure so and this also has happened in
our military and by the way hit like if
you hit the like button if you agree
with this is um i don't think that we're
less if i don't see how it's progress to
send women out to the front lines when
they are ill-equipped to be murdered in
the name of equality usually we would
have men go to war to protect the women
and children that's kind of why we go to
it's almost the most important resource
is women and children yeah that's our
most important that's how we populate
the country these are the people who
make up you're going to war not just for
land but to protect your citizens if
it's a defense of war instead we're
sending out women and children and we
are sending them out knowing that they
are not prepared now i am not saying
that a woman can't work on dispatch i'm
not saying that a woman can't be a pilot
i'm not saying a woman can't be a sniper
i'm saying that a woman can't do that
now 2018 let's look at this in the army
uh they implemented a gender-neutral
test
right that happened they said okay we're
going to do a gender-neutral test now
where everyone has to meet the same
standards
and they lowered the standards
had to be scrapped because women
couldn't pass it
so the gender neutral test 83 to 92
percent of men passed compared to a
maximum of 52 percent of women the
average was in the 40 something
percentile
that's terrible
this this should be an objective
standard like this is not one of those
things where you're like yeah we just
adjust the test to make sure everybody's
included and it also said it took into
account age no
if you're old you don't get to go fight
on the front line i'm sorry if you can't
pass the test you don't qualify
that's just how it is do you think that
that woman at that moment in time
thought oh oh
i've been screwed by the equality
[ __ ]
yeah probably i'm ill-prepared oh this
is not about
my vagina my opinion this is i'm about
to get this is going to hurt this is
real yeah yeah i probably just thought
uh oh yes i mean play this tape to the
end what happens if she's not on a
populated road where people thank you
citizens of ohio that stopped to help
out a police officer by the way that's
exactly what you should do what if she's
not around people though
that probably ends very poorly and guess
what we have another video of an officer
being attacked maybe even worse on dash
cam that makes the news well you see
that this is this is violence right but
you know where else you see it see it
with affirmative action in college you
see black people black americans who are
put into uh programs for example often
in stem fields they can get lower grades
right they can score lower on the sats
and and what happens is they fall back
they fall behind in class and they're
more likely to drop out of college when
you try and push you can either have
equal opportunity or you can try to
ensure equity of representation equity
and outcomes you cannot have both if
you're trying to engineer
right equity meaning equal
representation in the police force you
will inevitably
have to pull from a shallow talent pool
and you put them in danger so let's look
at the military again the fitness
standards okay for 22 to 26 year olds
the standing power throw for men at 6.3
meters because i scrapped the gender
neutral test for women it's four meters
these meters the sprint drag carry men
they have to do it in two minutes and 31
seconds for women three minutes and 15
seconds a two mile run
the men have 22 minutes the women have
23
and a 23 and a quarter hmm drag carry
like
the rupaul drag race yeah they do it at
the they do it at the uh the library
story i see okay i just wanted to just
reading a pop-out book gotcha but think
about this why hold on a second
none of this the very premise of
equality
in male dominated fields
it it disrupts its own outcome it's what
we need equality okay why because men
and women are the same okay but we want
40 percent longer and 40 lower standards
or 70 lower standards depending on what
it is uh for women to make it in why why
hold on a second it's a male dominated
field you said it was because of the
patriarchy
well look of course women should be able
to meet the same qualifications why
because your life is in danger and not
only is your life in danger guess who
else is in danger
people in your
in your platoon yeah
guess who else is you're citizens
are the people safer in that city
this this thing this house of cards has
to come tumbling down and the only way
that it works is if everything we do it
needs to be performance-based we need to
eliminate race we need to eliminate
gender we need to eliminate sexual
orientation sorry sex gender however
none of that should play a role in
combat positions
in police positions yeah in positions
that require any level of physical
strength they shouldn't because it makes
everyone else less safe yeah
it's that simple for their own good
there should be no neutralizing the
standards it should just be one high and
the bar should be higher by the way i'm
sorry 22 minutes for a
two mile run in the military ridiculous
what if that woman was trying to pull
back what if that woman was trying to
pull a rapist off of a woman yeah what
if she shows up i think she was well
yeah who would you want to show up
that's a good question to ask people
like if you're an injured soldier in a
combat situation do you want somebody
who did really poorly on the
the carry drag test that they were
talking about right if i'm in a burning
building and i have a female firefighter
show up say i'm carrying you out of here
there's going to be some backdrafts
because i'm opening a window and jumping
no no i'm good sir you're on fire yeah
yeah i know is this because i'm a woman
it's because you're five to eighty
pounds and weak two survivors that are
paralyzed from falling down a ladder
right
this happened to me at notre dame they
may they have a swim day it's a famous
test you have to pass a swim test to
graduate from the university of notre
dame you're telling me i think at one
point they were racist
they made an accommodation they allowed
water you have to do it so i i did my
swim test right after doing a really
heavy arm workout with with football
stuff and i yeah i was like man i'm
really tired and i looked and i had like
a five foot case 80 pound person as my
lifeguard and this is like a very deep
olympic-sized pool and i'm like
can you do the job yeah if i if i'm in
trouble you're taking
275 pounds of me out of this pool right
how much did they weigh i weighed 275 at
the time how much did they weigh
i'm sorry just he can't that's rude you
can't ask it of the woman who's supposed
to save your life she was under 100
pounds oh i thought you were saying she
was enormous dave let me put it to you
this way she was five foot nothing a
hundred and nothing oh yeah you would
have died at the bottom of that pool i
really would have been shooting swam
down and been like i can't help you
sorry there's a reason for weight
classes in combat between men
and women are physically weaker
okay it's that simple and we're making
people less safe do you think that
people in a neighborhood in a black
neighborhood for example people say oh
they don't trust police officers do you
think sending in a cop like that is
going to do very well and do you think
that's going to do
do anything for relations between
largely white police forces
and urban communities no what happens is
if that lady goes in she's not going to
de-escalate or should do this is a
perfect example too my parents
god lover my mom i was bullied as a kid
and this is something that a lot of
women don't understand is uh she would
say well if you're bullied you walk
right up to him and you tell him to stop
because he's you know what a lot of
these bullies just feel bad about
themselves and he kicked the crap out of
me now here's the thing
you cannot teach a child to defend
himself from a bully if and it's not
possible
if when it comes down to it your child
knows that they will lose a fight you
can only stand up to a bully if you know
that you can handle business when it
comes down to that time
women don't understand that with young
men generally speaking moms often ill
equip their sons
this woman is terrified deep down
because she knows that she can't handle
herself and that is someone who is more
dangerous you take someone who's afraid
who knows i can't handle myself in a
physical altercation but i've got a gun
that's a recipe for more shootings from
police yeah
you know who you want
you want the guy who can lock who can
hit you with the body lock suplex you
into the grass and cuff you and not
break a sweat because he never has to go
to his tool belt right and he knows that
he's calm and collect because he knows
he can defend himself if the situation
gets out of control and when you talk
about going to the tool belt i think it
was in chicago i can't remember but the
police officer the lady who reached for
what she thought was her taser and ended
up shooting the suspect well that was
just a stupid lady it was very stupid
but it wasn't a physical thing that was
a it allowed that was a brain thing you
said they have to go to their tool belt
yes and then it allows for problems like
that to happen where you overreact or
you make a mistake you get rid of choke
holds right some police departments get
rid of tasers right and then you add up
you add a bunch of diversity hires who
are ill-equipped they're not capable of
handling what happens you've now just
created a scenario for violence that's
why small people they they join gangs
they're weak they're scared weak people
incapable people physically are scared
they are more violent because they have
to be right crazy beats big very often
but you don't want your police officers
to be crazy that's why we don't want
them to be women now
that's not true terrible
[Laughter]
speaking of women
uh canadian prime minister justin
trudeau
he took time out of his trip to uh
england to honor the queen she's still
on the money there good what
not in the grave
oh what well i mean they probably
covered her eyes with some coins
she put the bucket
so uh justin trudeau did you see this
this is his trip to england he was doing
his best freddie mercury impression
[Applause]
okay sorry that's the wrong clip we need
to get that out of the uh get that out
of the board but here is prime minister
justin trudeau who uh like brian stelter
is a completely heterosexual male uh
doing queen even gayer than freddie
mercury did
he wishes
[Music]
he didn't have to do it in a gay
broadway
listen listen to him he's doing gay
broadway
that's enough
that's enough
he's doing the mary poppins version
he's doing it in aids minor
[Laughter]
and he's still off-key i know right
oh that's awesome freddie mercury wasn't
that gay no
by the way you heard william story about
freddie mercury yeah the masturbating
monkey yeah okay so gabe william is our
you know agent he's conservative he's
talking about a true story this is a
true story
this is a true story this is how you
make sure your writer is being read
friends yes yeah so i don't like my
writer like when we do these live shows
like what do you want in a green room
like i don't know toss in some snacks
like some some trail mix and uh i
usually just ask for like maybe an
energy drink
and i drink i drink hot water i drink
like tea before the show any live show
just that's it that's it and william's
like you need to put something in there
to make sure that they're paying
attention like ask for you want a bottle
of bourbon just something that someone
has to go and get so they're paying
attention
you know what the truth is freddie
mercury said freddie mercury i would
have in his writer that he needed a
masturbating monkey in the green room
always a masturbating monkey and i said
and the squirrels i don't know what i'm
going to do where am i going to find a
masturbating monkey and her someone
would work with freddie said oh oh
sweetheart
all monkeys are masturbating monkeys
they just do you can't stop
that's
them
yeah that's why like the green m ms and
all those things you hear people like
can you believe that it's like that's
because they want to make sure their
writer is being read right yeah so if
you walk in and there's a monkey in your
green room you're like well they
certainly read it yes they absolutely
read it and uh unfortunately we have to
euthanize him yes it seems like it's a
gag that maybe goes overboard somebody
get the monkey a diaper please also
that's where aids came from yes yes uh
monkey
and freddie ironically not monkey pox no
no monkey pox just came from dudes yeah
yep aged the monkeys yeah well at least
all the people around you nature's cruel
mysteries were having a good time at
least they were having they were having
a laugh long story short there's one
thing i have on my rider
yeah yep
masturbating monkey yep i think we
always now you do yeah
we could have dual masturbating monkeys
that's right we each have like i have to
have one and he has to have one
no no one has a boy cowboy hat one has a
girl cowboy hat it's settled go see him
in bay city go see us in nashville there
will be masturbating monkeys there will
not be now uh here's one thing that was
a british rabble rouser told trudeau to
uh i love this guy to screw off back to
canada this guy is inc this guy he's an
englishman but he's talking to the
canadian prime minister who of course uh
you know saying he said i want to sing
freddie mercury only make it gayer and
it rubbed this guy the wrong way
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's got
[Music]
[Laughter]
how did you feel good about yourself
when you just sang on a piano you know
like a like a lady in the old west yes
yeah
are you wearing a bustle he really was
though he was just singing like he's in
a like a piano lounge and it's just a
girl laying on a piano and then
everybody walks out and tells you how
awful you are i would just i would love
to get that guy in the show yeah by the
way his comment about trudeau being a
bastard is right on point factually
speaking just so you know yeah and i'm
always thinking by the way also liam
neeson could do that
look at that last sure look at that last
that is liam neeson playing a castro it
is
he's got a special set of skills i've
got a very particular set of skills
human accent is not chief amongst them i
will destroy the entire island economy
yeah and i won't allow you to play the
saxophone ever
i was born in america in this movie yes
i don't believe you because of me you
have a gage named william that was an
amistad yes and then after that
everything was a sequel and even the
non-taken sequels are still basically
taken sequels taken three is ridiculous
have you seen the one
the midnight train yes it's just taken
on a train have you seen walk amongst
the tombstones yes it's taken amongst
the tombstones
that was the working title but they said
it would be too much taken taken with
wolves
did you see that you saw the grey yes
yes it was supposed to be the taken
they were like hey i took taken and
instead of bad guys in russia i wrote
worlds yes
and i killed them by taving broken glass
bottles to my knuckles that's not true
which would do far more damage to myself
yes yeah that'd be a layers you punch a
wolf it's your hands just bleeding and
the wolf is eating you yes
this didn't work at all
it's a horrible idea i thought it was
gonna be like wolverine turns out that's
just not real life electrical tape that
doesn't even hold yeah it's also very
cold it would it's just all the sticky
wore off you know what i told the man
who told me to to tape broken bottles to
my hand that resulted in me losing my
hand to the wolf what's that he was
taking me for a ride
now i'm going to go make taken on a
plane
i'm tired of this [ __ ] taken so
now taking the snakes
all right hey by the way it's a live
show monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern if you miss it uh you can always
watch it on rumble you can watch it on
mug club of course we're gonna do an
extra 45 minutes today on uh mug club is
that are we talking about the uh
adam levine thing yes oh yeah his little
mistress yeah his victim victim poor
poor cheating [ __ ]
is that the feller from maroon 5
i don't care for him do you know the
thing about him but
he will be loved oh
he will
take it in the band somebody please take
me out of here
liam neeson sings the classics yeah
just sitting in for maroon 5.
you're beautiful
you're beautiful it's true
yeah i saw your face
in a crowded place i don't i don't i
don't know what to do
but then you were gone
and i had to make some calls
all right cut
let's just bring in tim mcgraw i can't
go on not allowing you i like it i think
that's gonna make it pop so
that's better than i did yeah he's he's
better yeah he's he's the artist i'm
more of a taken type yes
have we done boat taken
[Laughter]
yes i could be a lady maybe a lady
yeah they could have a particular set of
skills as they could take a boy coach
and i could go undercover
as a black lady
and it would be called
taken like me all right speaking of
undercover and this is how absurd i know
you may say hey this is this is a silly
example no this is what this is what i
hope that you understand here
when we show you these stories that i'm
about to show you but this trans
canadian teacher at one point in time
you would have said oh you're just
taking extreme fringe examples before we
had drag queen story hour right now it's
the norm
this and it's not that in canada what
you were about to see is silly it's
absurd it's disgusting and i mean
disgusting because it's a gross
violation of basic dress code laws at
any school
it's that the the school board decided
they were going to defend this as
legitimate and so i want if nothing else
from this show what i hope you do is
is you go and you read the original
sources that's why we make all the
references available at
lateralcredit.com and i want you to see
their argument for their position it's
yes you may think that this is silly but
i want you to try and examine why are
they trying to present this with the
setup that they do we've talked about
that a lot in christian apologetics if
you look at the early persecutors of
christianity a lot of them would say
well yes jesus was crucified and it's an
empty tomb but it was stolen by the
apostles in other words the easiest
thing in the world would have been to
say there's no empty tomb there was no
jesus christ they didn't do that if you
look at what they're doing in canada
they say yes this is absurd that this
man is wearing giant fake
prosthetic tits in class and spandex
shorts but
this is their true identity now any
example of you claiming to be your true
self and by that i mean prosthetics or
by that i mean sex reassignment surgery
or hormones that will put you in an
early cancerous grave as long as you
claim it's your true self because we're
beyond the realms of science now people
say well we who are we to question their
authentic self so i want you to comment
here below and just hit the like button
that helps with the algorithm uh if you
can see
why
this is an example that i think we need
to pay attention to and not just because
it's so understand how absurd it is when
you watch this you won't believe me and
then understand that it was defended by
the school board this guy sorry she she
is still doing this this is a shop
teacher in canada
no audio on this yeah
your boobs are huge
[Laughter]
this is how you cut he has to change the
way he's teaching shop
it would be a sketch ten years ago yeah
yeah yeah yeah looks like listen the
wood shop teachers made some changes
over the summer let's not say anything
when she arrives what do you mean she
you talking about ron yeah
yes yes
[Laughter]
yes big titted ron yes yes what do you
mean big did it ron
listen
all in good time you have you ever seen
the spencer's greeting card with a
gigantic breasted woman yes that's wrong
which is also where he purchased the
breasts
also look at this plasma orb isn't that
fun that's fun
whatever you do don't look at his giant
ridiculous breasts exactly you don't do
that you all get plasma orbs and fart
spray and i think we're all winners here
so here's the thing the reason that this
is public is because students were
complaining now the school board said oh
all the students love this teacher no
some students were saying this is
inappropriate it makes me uncomfortable
i can imagine why i had okay
[Music]
i had a greek teacher i was just saying
miss chronopolis she was a wonderful
teacher and she did not dress
inappropriately
she had large breasts okay
she couldn't help it
uh
she couldn't help but none of it i don't
know about it right but i remember one
time she was leaning she was like
leaning over and helping correct my work
and her
her breasts ever so slightly like brush
my shoulder and you know that's just
like you just hit the nuke for a teenage
boy
like the bell rang like why aren't you
leaving like i think i need to rest
so same thing happened with a guy named
mr harold yes
his helmet rubbed me can you imagine
this guy washing your hair in the sink
so
the kids were complaining now keep in
mind women are not allowed to dress this
way right women are not allowed to wear
spandex shorts
and i don't know about the top honestly
i don't know about the black i don't
know about the
early early 19th century french prison
or black stripes but uh kids were
complaining the ontario school board
they claim that they stand by the trans
shop teacher's choice uh not only in the
prosthetic breasts but in the skin tight
shirts the tops and the shorts that
women are not allowed to wear now here's
the thing this is also you know what you
just saw on instagram you fell on
instagram that remember that transgender
male in the letterman's jacket yeah who
threw a homeless man's lunch box at me
our follow-up video was removed because
we laughed remember that they said that
we were misgen they said that we were
mocking this person's existence because
now the trans issue right you don't have
to go through hormones you don't have to
do the bottom half
you just need to say that you're a woman
and however you choose to present
yourself
is now by society declared certainly in
canada to be
your true self kamala harris is a good
example she says it's very important for
example she tweeted out everyone
deserves to be their true self without
harassment or discrimination this
matters and my point is i don't know how
that gets juxtaposed with the idea of
you know what you don't have to meet
these unrealistic beauty standards think
about it this guy is clearly trying to
fit into a sorry woman into a stereotype
at what point do you say if it was a
young girl who said i need giant triple
d tits
you would say well you know what maybe
you have an unhealthy body image because
you're beautiful just the way god made
you when a man says i need giant triple
d tits
oh this is brave and beautiful so we
actually decided to see just how
authentic this is and how people can
live with their true self and everyone
in this office was forced to wear giant
prosthetic breasts
[Applause]
why i'm not honking at you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you're lopsided there just get the other
one
higher it's
just it might
just
and by the way
the reason we're doing this it seems
silly and childish
you got there it's just so that you can
see
how uh how ridiculous it is for this to
be someone's authentic self it's
impractical it's convenient right here
though it kind of holds them does it
hold a microphone i've never felt so
mean it's like
like
taken with tits someone who says i don't
feel like me
unless i have this is a psychopath liar
it's a psychopath
oh geez i lost one can we get gerald
another tip oh he's got him ah she's got
a single mastectomy so my question to
you is ladies ladies too
are these actually no don't pop them yet
don't think it's just an accident yeah
okay let's keep them going it's a sexy
accident it's just a sexy sexy accident
it can be like a you know
it would be funny if this wasn't being
taken seriously this is being taken
seriously think about this look see how
silly this is see i'll see look look
see how silly this is
i could be teaching your children
and if your children complain and say
this makes me uncomfortable
in my class because it's a guy with a
five o'clock shadow and giant fake tits
the school board will silence your
child's voice and say no no most kids
the mob rule of the majority like this
teacher and we stand by this
we stand by this a school board
all right kids we're going to be doing
woodworking today
look at me just grab any wood you like
any wood
oh boy we're going to be doing physical
science later he's going to be
dissecting a sheep's eye come on who
wants to hold the wood while the iris
bounces she'll have a lot of fun with
that
[Music]
what's happening sorry titties
there's no way to do your work it's hard
how could you possibly function this is
my authentic true self this is no more
silly than that teacher who was
supported by the school board and by the
way no more silly than the first female
not woman
four star admirable who's the assistant
health secretary this is no more silly
it is silly
i hate myself
i don't like myself placement there we
go
and neither should that person
dave you look a little antsy i i have to
pee
with those yeah
it's a hormonal thing yeah well yeah
i've i i don't have a i've already gone
four times this morning i ha i have a uh
bladder
did you just ask me that
go
go pee
[Music]
all right
ah
all right
good steaks here good ranch or steaks
here 15 good ranch of steaks best meat
you your mama ever had who wants to stay
i'll take one oh yeah these are the best
i know i remember you from last week
yeah how's the kids
still not mine
damn what the hell are you doing well
i'll tell you what i'm not doing and
that's stealing the stakes the good
rancher sends us and selling them as a
side hustle okay good because that's
what i thought you were doing all right
we'll see you back in the show
[Music]
man he really can get in and out of them
titties quickly yes guess that's what
happens when they're not real hey do you
know how i know that your brooms aren't
authentic they're not real they're
removable by the way uh good ranchers
they're sponsor they have the i met
actually the good guy who runs the good
ranchers in houston yeah uh here's one
thing i will say is there's a meat
shortage coming this is not a doomsday
thing and a big part of it is because it
comes from overseas the good ranchers
guys they use only um usda prime or
upper choice of beef uh and uh it's uh
from american farms small american farms
yeah they actually buy from small
american farms you go to goodreads.com
crowder use the code crowder you can do
either or and you get 30 off plus free
express shipping on any box and i think
you lock in that price right yeah
absolutely so then they have the balls
to sponsorship not the breast they don't
they don't have the breast to sponsor
yes they might although they do call me
a meat market they call me mr tits yep
comment name that film reference it was
modified
yes
[Laughter]
do we have to wear these the rest of
this yes we do yes we do because we're
all
what do you mean where you mean do we
have to be our authentic selves well get
to win you're more authentic than i am
it looks guys i'm gay you know how i
know that i'm lower class what with the
good rancher stuff you know what i eat
more than the steaks as i eat the waigu
burgers and i just i do them like a
salisbury steak i put cheese on them and
i just eat them like i prefer them
because you're supposed to like smash i
know but i prefer am i the only one like
i prefer sometimes burger meat to steak
yeah i do if you have good burger meat
you put some cheese on there yeah it's
delicious all right lopsided like my
first girlfriend
or you you know who i am
it's a weird day so uh desantis
governor ron desantis who i just love
the guy just he just plays street bully
[ __ ] rejected whatever it is that comes
his way he's under investigation now why
is he under investigation okay you have
texas's uh bexar bexar county sheriff
uh he plans to open an investigation
into the florida governor ron desantis
after he they they quote say lured
migrants to fly them now you know about
this he sent them to martha's vineyard
but now the claim is that he misled them
and lured them to martha's vineyard
which really shouldn't matter if you're
pro-migrant period you should be happy
that they show up anywhere but i'd like
to get in a little bit deeper than oh
liberals don't like them in their
backyard because there's there's a
little bit more at play here but here's
a clip of the sheriff uh complaining and
talking about opening an investigation
which is of course more political
theater to answer i guess just a bunch
of questions we've been getting
throughout the day uh in piecemeal
fashion put his
we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected
activities involving the
48 migrants from venezuela as we
understand it 48 migrants that's why
they were
uh lured i i will use the word lord uh
under false pretenses uh on into into
staying at a hotel on a vacation for a
couple of days uh they were taken by an
airplane at a certain point they were
shuttled to an airplane
uh where they were put up in a bed
and then eventually flown to martha's
vineyard again under false pretenses
the information that we have
that they were promised work they were
promised the solution to several of
their problems they were none of that
they were taken to
uh martha's vineyard from what from what
we can gather uh for nothing for a
little more than a photo op video op
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded
in martha's vineyard okay so a couple of
things here that i want to touch first
off like you said they showed up and the
mayor of ammunity was not happy i'll be
damned if my if my labor day weekend
gets ruined by a bunch of brownies
[Laughter]
so um
wow my dad has that suit loans look
great
wow all of a sudden
so let me first point something out to
you
that's a man who could come and take
your guns away yeah so people say back
the blue not that blue
not that blue that we saw earlier i want
to make it really clear i think we need
efficient and we need constitutionally
constrained local law enforcement and i
think we need to do away with the
federalization of police the fbi now the
irs because we're going to be arming
more agents the cia i don't think that
we need the kind of militarized national
police force and i think that we need to
hold loc
make sure you pay attention your local
elections make sure you know who your
local sheriff is this is the kind of man
i guarantee you who would gladly strip
you of your rights because he has a
badge and some power because
he right there was pushing propaganda
it's not true he even added this is from
the miami he even added at this point
i'm not able to definitively say
here's the statute that they broke
either federal state or local but what i
can tell you is it's wrong so in other
words there is no reason for an
investigation other than he thinks it's
wrong for these migrants to be sent
somewhere less convenient and by the way
he's not even in that city right there's
nothing illegal
he's going to launch an investigation
that's a stunt you know what else is a
stunt
rating
the former president or sitting
president depending how people out there
refer to donald trump's home in
mar-a-lago there still haven't been
arrests yeah
nothing and pretending you care you just
said it he's basically decrying this as
a political stunt basically he said oh
they were unceremoniously left there yes
the locals snapped pictures posted it on
facebook and then deported them to the
national card and said can you please
get these people out of here yeah you
are doing the exact same thing opening
an investigation because that's where
they took off from and you think there's
a problem but you can't point out that
there's actually a problem don't you
typically find like ah that's the law
that was broken you did it yeah we're
gonna investigate you raped her that's
illegal he's the pusher you know
yeah we noticed they were migrants
because they looked nothing like us yes
at all they didn't blend in whatsoever
as other human beings especially in
martha's vineyard yes the richest area
ever baller move
if they showed up with a few like weed
whackers they would have been like oh
yeah it's just we've got that's just a
record guy so here's something else just
let's just cut this off with the pass
they were not lured what we're going to
lure him name that movie
uh desantis explained exactly governor
desantis um how they well knew what was
going on here you can just watch this
for yourself and by the way just for the
record this was voluntary all migrants
were put up in hotels given
accommodations they were fed they were
showered they were offered haircuts and
and any other services that they were
needed correct
yeah not only that they all signed
consent forms to go and then the vendor
that is doing this for florida provided
them with a packet that had a map of
martha's vineyard it had the numbers for
different services on martha's vineyard
and then it had numbers for the overall
agencies in massachusetts that handle
things involving immigration and
refugees so it was clearly voluntary and
all the other nonsense you're hearing um
is just not true okay so first off this
is why the guy said well it's just not
really true what the media wants to
cover is a sheriff launching an
investigation just like the media wants
to cover the rate of donald trump they
don't want to follow up on the fact that
there should have been arrests within
two days there should have been arrests
immediately if there were crimes
committed we know that there weren't
that's why we know it's a publicity
stunt this is not a publicity stunt this
is meant to point out exactly what what
this current administration is doing the
former vice president joe biden and his
administration they've been flying
migrants around the country since taking
office august 2021 there was there were
2000 flown in new york december 2021.
there were 130 mostly miners flown to
pennsylvania this is not new the issue
is that it's usually done in the dark
yes what they don't like is sunlight
they don't like sunlight as a
disinfectant this happens all the time
joe pine does this exact thing yeah all
the time and by the way you said it in
the dark uh literally they did it at
night so that nobody would be able to
see what was going on and they're just
taking these people and throwing them in
different communities and not asking the
community and this is why they can't
have donald trump are they vampires this
is why they can't have donald trump
remember remember when donald trump the
debate is you know what his most
effective phrase was who built the cages
joe yeah who built the cages jill
remember when they were trying to say
donald trump putting kids in cages the
pictures were taken from the obama era
so if donald trump write if donald trump
were the person with the media right now
and they were saying can you believe
they sent these migrants he would say
who flew the migrants first who flew
them first huh wasn't there 2000 i think
it was something like 2000 and he always
knows exactly what it is but he says
like i think he's like i heard there was
something like 2004 something like that
sent to new york who set the joke who
built the cages joe who's been shipping
migrants across this country joe who has
created a border crisis the likes of
which this country has never seen joe
and by the way while we're talking about
this the libertarians out there you're
wrong where is this this is a waste of
taxpayer dollars no
12 million dollars that's true it was in
the budget okay the government allocated
this to relocate illegal immigrants okay
so people look at that and say that's a
lot of money couldn't that be better
used insert whatever social program they
want here liberals don't actually live
in the constitutional parameters of
government they say couldn't that be
better used to provide more ebt cards
okay 12 million dollars all right
to draw attention to illegal immigrants
to draw attention to the border crisis
that is taking place that most liberals
don't have to live with in their
communities illegal immigration illegal
immigrants in this country cost you the
taxpayer 116
billion dollars annually that's why when
libertarians would say a wall might cost
40 40 billion dollars the real estimates
were about 25 billion you can go back to
build a wall change my mind all these
references are there
116 billion dollar dollars annually
that means you're talking about close to
right now at least 240 billion dollars
and this is these are old numbers yeah
it's probably more now it's probably
closer to 300 billion just since biden
has taken office right because the
numbers of immigrants coming over
illegal immigrants coming into this
country has skyrocketed under biden
because he knows things like this will
happen like you can get to this country
and this will happen to you right yes
more right it's much better it's that
shrink-flation yes well yeah the cost of
goods haven't gone up they're just
smaller they're everything is fun-sized
you see kind bars have you seen this
this [ __ ] now like uh good for an
afternoon snack our kind they just cut
the bar in half like better lower
calories so you can snack smart what and
you're just giving me less food
next time it's just gonna be a rapper
i'll just smell the wrapper fattis
that's all you're getting like you're
not
yeah they're this big that really
yeah we had them in our green room yeah
i was like what is this this is a square
like no no that's the new diet friendly
kind bar it's the mini well can you
bring someone
from kind here so i know who to shoot
yeah how much is it figuratively same
price same price yes same price you get
half for shame
we just sorry it's the boobs it's the
boobs you can't yeah
it just gets in the way but it's hard to
live your authentic self yeah
can you milk me greg
like matthew mcconaughey on the beach
i mean if that's all you're doing all
day
i'm sorry i'm a child this is far too
fun
anyway 116 billion versus 12 million and
by the way 12 million well spent because
it pissed all the right people off and i
think that that counts for something so
the plane used to fly the migrants
martha's vineyard by the way is also
scheduled for a flight from san antonio
to delaware
uh i don't really know why that matters
just a little fun fact so migrants from
venezuela cuba and nicaragua are up 175
from last august and i know this
particularly because you know um you can
still go to cigars daily and actually i
think we still have more of the crowd or
seven plus one samplers but there's been
a problem with the cigar industry for
example because
rollers in a lot of these countries
these are high-paying jobs these are
really actually sort of coveted jobs
well now they're leaving
they're leaving because any even though
it's a good paying job in nicaragua
anything in the united states is better
than even a good paying job in italy
yeah so there's a real problem certain
years of cigars can no longer be found
because there's a there's a shortage of
rollers but here's something that i
would like
i would like to to to to pose here and
you guys can comment below and by the
way again hit like share
helps with the algorithm i just ask that
you do
the left says okay the reason that these
people can come here to this country
illegally is they're asylum seekers
right right that's the only way you can
justify it well let's ignore the fact
that sometimes i've had to traverse
through like seven countries to get here
uh okay venezuela cuba places like
nicaragua so asylum means you're
persecuted by a government right
these are all socialist countries
so the left has to say well these people
should be allowed in the united states
because they're seeking asylum from the
policies that we seek to impose
how do i know look at bernie sanders's
quotes on venezuela
look at what they've said about look at
when barack obama went to cuba
look look at the policies and look who
they try and mimic look who they try and
emulate so i don't i don't think that
that holds water you're not being
persecuted if you're leaving a country
just because it's socialist and it's
crappy and these countries are they are
crappy because of their socialist
policies i think that someone for
example a christian fleeing china should
be an asylum seeker to their nearest
neighboring country i think a christian
fleeing syria fleeing isis that's
someone who is facing actual religious
persecution i would actually argue
pastors who face jail time for not
closing down during covet in canada
those people have a more legitimate
claim to asylum than people from
nicaragua than people from cuba unless
unless democrats admit
that socialism is inherently persecutory
against people's individual freedoms in
which case you have to change your
entire platform
i don't know
is that hold water can't have it both
ways
wow they're seeking asylum from what
from the [ __ ] that we want to do here
yes yes oh okay so now you have the left
they've labeled uh you know desantis and
uh repub all the republican
front-runners right for 2024 desantis
trump uh fascists and they've opened
investigations into them
don't be don't don't don't be led by the
nose here they're just they're looking
for a reason to bog down desantis
because they think okay we've shackled
donald trump with the raids with the
investigations
now desantis seems like he might
actually do the kinds of things that
donald trump has also done he's an
outsider we need to do we need to burden
him well as you heard that sheriff say
there's no statute that's violated we're
going we're going to investigate him
anyway why because it makes it harder
for him to run for office remember how
hard it was for you to do this show when
you were being audited yes
you were constantly having to leave
early like sorry i got to deal with my
account i know it drains you that's what
they are trying to do and so now they've
compared the right trump desantis the
people who are being falsely
investigated to nazis so here's the
co-founder of race two dinner uh saira
rao she's like a blue check mark but
also really
really big in the leftist community
tweeted this is a trump rally from last
night
at a glance it could be nazi germany
they were lifting their hands in prayer
yeah by the way
lifting their hands in prayer it could
also be any concert yes exactly
no no but they don't have a problem with
any concert right they have a problem
with lifting your hands in prayer yes
saying it's nazi germany and then she
goes on to say if you are a republican
you are a nazi if you are married to
dating or friends with a republican you
are married to dating or friends with a
nazi if you don't speak if you don't
want to be a nazi speak up
now
this means nazi symbol if you're holding
your hand up and gerald we've done that
in our church yeah all right both hands
up gosh i must have been really
committed yeah that's a double hail yeah
yeah no seek or just just the it's a
double hail yeah yeah yeah it's it's
it's i mean it's one of those it's not
against the rules it's frowned upon upon
yes yes it's too much hail this is a
white supremacist symbol yes this is a
white supremacist so now this lifting
your hand in prayer is nazism don't pray
what's the next step well canada what is
that we shut down your church what's the
next step well china what's that you're
arrested if you have a bible yeah what's
this
oh it's white supremacy remember we had
people in the military they were saying
they were flashing a white supremacist
gang symbol so what happens after jail
macaulay culkin for the cover of
homolone 2.
i use this all the time when we're doing
things on it why because this usually
means turn it up this will mean turn it
down and this means we're good i can't
do a thumbs up this means we're good
this isn't a white supremacist symbol
they want you to be afraid to pray they
want if they plant in your brain
just a little bit when you're in church
and this is how they win it's a game of
inches it's if you do this and in your
head you're going oh i hope i don't get
accused of being a nazi guess what
that's a win for them if you see some
guy with giant fake stupid prosthetic
spencer's tits and you go i don't think
that's a woman but i'm afraid to ooh
they just won if you say i'm not sure
that full-grown men should be in the
girls restroom but i don't want to speak
up boom they've just this is a playbook
the reason the reason i read this for
you
is right here this is a trump rally from
last night at glantz it could be nazi
germany don't want you to pray in church
right away they've attacked christians
for praying in church we see the church
shrinking if you are a republican you
are a nazi they want you to be afraid to
identify as a republican if you are
married to dating or friends of the
republican you are dating or they don't
want you to even associate with people
they don't want you to even have friends
this is this is the playbook and by the
way it's the playbook of who
the nazis
if you don't want to be a nazi speak up
are they saying speak no they're saying
if you see something say something think
about this for a second the people
saying speak up
they're saying it
on a platform
that has knowingly suppressed political
speech
and not only hunter biden story they
have knowingly suppressed people who are
conservative on twitter on facebook on
youtube right we've been demonetized we
know that they have knowingly suppressed
those people with the support of the
current federal government and they want
to tell you speak up what do they mean
be a lackey be it quizzling do the
bidding of this government and again i
never back down from the comparison
people sometimes try and say oh you
actually think hitler was a leftist yes
absolutely not only because it's in the
title national socialist workers party
but if you look at their policies on gun
control if you look at their policies on
speech if you look at their policies on
personal freedoms if you look at their
policies on abortion and eugenics you
try and find me a comparison between
donald trump and hitler that is more apt
than this lady on twitter or kamala
harris or joe biden beyond the fact that
miriam webster or google tells you that
fascism is inherently right-wing
you don't think you're living under
fascism right now you can't speak out
against this
and if you send illegal immigrants to a
liberal area just like the former vice
president has done they're going to
launch an investigation into you and
then the people who will do their
bidding i guarantee you this broad is
met with some people the white house
tells you don't even be friends with
republicans don't raise your hands in
prayer and if you see people doing this
if you see something say something the
nazi comparison is old and tired but by
god it has never been more appropriate
than with the democratic party today
it's not even
close
all right i think i've
given my thoughts
[Music]
that's fair that's a good point anyone
have anything to add
no i think we've all made uh points i
think we have these these are starting
to hurt my back yes uh my neck hurts
very bad well guess what that's just the
price you pay for being beautiful yeah
by the way women out there do not get a
breast reduction it's like slapping god
in the face
it's true you sleep take one for your
arm take one for the team take two
all right
share the show if you're watching on
youtube we're gonna go on now to uh this
is something we can not discuss no uh on
the youtube adam levine's uh adam
levine's horror mistress and i don't
know if you know this but she's a victim
she's a home nowadays i don't know if
you notice we used to call them home
records you know what you call them
today
uh the real heroes yeah yeah
yes the real heroes share the show hit
like comment we are going to see you
tomorrow love you we're going to youtube
sorry we're going off youtube mug club
you know the piss off the piss piss off
[Music]
you